Speaker 1: Hello, LA.
Speaker 1: You're up way past your bedtime, aren't you?
Speaker 1: Hope you've slipped into something comfortable.
Speaker 1: I know I have.
Speaker 1: If you're new to town or just new to this whole radio thing, you're
Speaker 1: listening to The Deb of Night, the only girl who will spend the night
Speaker 1: with you and leave first thing in the morning, guaranteed.
Speaker 1: Well, looks like the boards are lighting up.
Speaker 1: Aren't I the popular one?
Speaker 1: Let's see.
Speaker 1: Eenie meenie miney mo, who will be the lucky caller?
Speaker 1: You've got the first shot at Deb tonight.
Speaker 1: So who do I have the pleasure of speaking to?
Speaker 2: Hi, Deb.
Speaker 2: This is, uh, Vigo.
Speaker 1: Vigo.
Speaker 1: So, Vigo, why are you up so late?
Speaker 2: Um, I'm working the late shift here at the, uh, yacht club.
Speaker 1: Uh-huh.
Speaker 1: How many boats do you own, Vigo?
Speaker 2: Two.
Speaker 2: Actually, three.
Speaker 2: Uh, one is, uh, in the shop.
Speaker 1: I used to do a little yachting myself.
Speaker 1: What brand of yacht do you have?
Speaker 2: Um, you probably wouldn't know the brand.
Speaker 2: I, uh, bought them in Italy.
Speaker 1: Ah, l'Italia bella.
Speaker 1: Parlate italiano?
Speaker 2: Um,
Speaker 2: yes.
Speaker 1: Arrivederci, Vigo.
Speaker 1: Caller two, you're on The Deb of Night.
Speaker 1: Be gentle.
Speaker 3: Hi, Deb.
Speaker 1: Hello, caller.
Speaker 1: Is tonight a rerun?
Speaker 3: Deb.
Speaker 1: Caller number three, what's keeping you up tonight?
Speaker 4: Deb, listen to me, Deb.
Speaker 4: They're at it again, and people have got to know.
Speaker 4: They've got to know because they don't know.
Speaker 4: They won't report this stuff on the news because they own the news.
Speaker 1: Hello, Gomez.
Speaker 1: What's the latest conspiracy?
Speaker 4: Conspiracy?
Speaker 4: This goes beyond conspiracy, okay?
Speaker 4: There's no word for something as devious and secret as this, you understand?
Speaker 4: The people need to hear this.
Speaker 4: They need to know the real story.
Speaker 1: You've got our undivided attention.
Speaker 4: All right.
Speaker 4: As we all know, the Americans established a moon base back in the late
Speaker 4: seventies.
Speaker 4: That's no secret.
Speaker 4: But what most people don't know is that they have been conducting a dig,
Speaker 4: not for resources, but for artifacts.
Speaker 1: I see.
Speaker 4: Well, it's no coincidence that the Chinese have started conducting space missions.
Speaker 4: You know why?
Speaker 4: I'll tell you why.
Speaker 4: The reason is because the Chinese are trying to stop the Americans from finding
Speaker 4: an ancient space probe sent by the Beta Centaurians.
Speaker 4: And why?
Speaker 4: Because the Beta Centaurians are giving space technology to the Chinese to get back
Speaker 4: at the Andromedans, AKA the Grays, for giving space technology to the Americans in
Speaker 4: the fifties.
Speaker 1: Fascinating.
Speaker 4: The American government's been putting more money into space.
Speaker 4: Don't you see what's happening?
Speaker 4: I can't believe I'm the only one that's figured it out.
Speaker 4: Am I the only person alive that can see what's going on?
Speaker 4: It's because the Andromedans and the Betas are going to be fighting their war
Speaker 4: in this galaxy through us, Deb, and the American people, the people of Earth,
Speaker 4: you people cannot let this happen.
Speaker 4: It's Mu versus Atlantis all over again.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Gomez, and that concludes the news portion of the show.
Speaker 1: Well, this girl's got to pay her bills, so it's time for a few
Speaker 1: commercials, but don't go anywhere.
Speaker 1: I'm just getting warmed up, or should I say hot.
Speaker 5: Friggin Chicken recently challenged several random people to a taste test between Friggin Chicken
Speaker 5: and the other leading chicken flavored products.
Speaker 5: Let's listen for which one they preferred.
Speaker 6: Ma'am, care to participate in a taste test?
Speaker 6: Here, try this leading brand of chicken.
Speaker 7: Ugh!
Speaker 7: Oh my gosh!
Speaker 7: Is that week-old fish?
Speaker 6: Now try this.
Speaker 7: Oh.
Speaker 7: Oh!
Speaker 7: This is some good [beep] chicken.
Speaker 7: What is this?
Speaker 6: Sir, take a test for me.
Speaker 8: Sure.
Speaker 8: Um, hmm.
Speaker 8: Huh.
Speaker 8: Seriously, job these up your [beep].
Speaker 6: Here, try this one.
Speaker 8: Hmm.
Speaker 8: Hey.
Speaker 8: Mother [beep] great chicken right there.
Speaker 8: What is this?
Speaker 6: It's Friggin Chicken.
Speaker 8: This is cat, right?
Speaker 8: Are you feeding me cat?
Speaker 6: Try this.
Speaker 8: Holy [beep].
Speaker 8: [beep] that's good.
Speaker 8: What the [beep] is this [beep]?
Speaker 5: Nine out of ten people preferred Friggin Chicken over the competition.
Speaker 5: Why?
Speaker 8: 'Cause that's some good [beep] chicken.
Speaker 8: I mean, Friggin Chicken.
Speaker 5: Friggin Chicken, you'll swear it's the best you've ever had.
Speaker 5: You loved the talking baby movie and the talking pig and even the talking
Speaker 5: car in that show.
Speaker 5: You know the one I'm talking about.
Speaker 5: But now prepare for the most hilarious talkingest normally mute object yet.
Speaker 5: He's Steve Cash, a New York banker and recent widower down on his luck.
Speaker 6: And ten makes one hundred.
Speaker 6: Here's your money, ma'am.
Speaker 2: Ma'am, I happen to have a glandular problem.
Speaker 2: That's it.
Speaker 2: I'm withdrawing all my millions from this bank.
Speaker 9: Cash!
Speaker 5: [laughing] She's an ATM machine with the soul of his dead wife.
Speaker 6: There's something familiar about this ATM machine.
Speaker 3: I love you.
Speaker 6: Wow, those marketing guys are geniuses.
Speaker 5: [laughing] Together, they're learning to make the most of their special situation.
Speaker 3: So that girl from accounting used me today.
Speaker 6: Really?
Speaker 3: She wasn't like everybody else.
Speaker 3: When she pushed my buttons, she was very gentle.
Speaker 6: Oh, honey, if you don't stop, I'm gonna have to make a deposit.
Speaker 5: [laughing]
Speaker 5: Transferring Cash, Wednesdays at eight thirty in the BMC.
Speaker 5: Say goodbye to yellow teeth and spots on your dirty dishes.
Speaker 8: It's incredible.
Speaker 7: Look at that shine.
Speaker 8: Your smile or these dinner plates?
Speaker 5: [laughing] Harnessing the secrets of ancient Egypt, now there's a dishwashing detergent so powerful
Speaker 5: it doesn't just leave your dishes spotless, it actually whitens your teeth.
Speaker 5: Patented time-release spiritoids remove caked on food and grease and remain on the plate
Speaker 5: to be absorbed into your food to clean your teeth while you eat.
Speaker 5: Dazatron, the dishwashing detergent of the future, for cleaner plates and whiter teeth.
Speaker 5: Last year, Democratic candidate Michael Rebens bought a sports utility vehicle.
Speaker 5: Three months later, there were two separate incidences of hit-and-runs by an unidentified SUV
Speaker 5: in his area.
Speaker 5: Is Democratic candidate Michael Rebens to blame?
Speaker 5: Can you afford to take that chance?
Speaker 5: Can your children?
Speaker 5: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorn, a candidate that has never committed vehicular homicide.
Speaker 5: Democratic candidate Michael Rebens has never publicly stated his opinion on child pornography.
Speaker 5: Is it because he's hiding something?
Speaker 5: Would you want a child pornographer voting on this nation's laws?
Speaker 5: Would you trust your children's future to someone like that?
Speaker 5: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorn, the candidate that is committed to locking up child
Speaker 5: pornographers.
Speaker 5: Democratic candidate Michael Rebens recently sued Senator Robert Thorn for accusing Rebens of being
Speaker 5: a murderous child pornographer.
Speaker 5: But Rebens had previously said he was against clogging up courts with frivolous lawsuits.
Speaker 5: Wouldn't this make him a hypocrite?
Speaker 5: Would you want a hypocrite as your next congressman?
Speaker 5: Would you want your children to become hypocrites?
Speaker 5: Vote Republican Senator Robert Thorn, a candidate not accused of being a murderous child
Speaker 5: pornographer.
Speaker 1: In a world where people live and die.
Speaker 9: Do you think you can just go in there and handle this by yourself?
Speaker 2: If that's what it takes.
Speaker 1: He was about to meet his greatest foe.
Speaker 9: Kill them all, all of them.
Speaker 1: And a girl.
Speaker 2: Hello.
Speaker 3: Hi.
Speaker 1: And a comic relief sidekick who won't make it to act three.
Speaker 9: I picked the wrong month to cancel my life insurance.
Speaker 2: No, don't say that.
Speaker 2: You're gonna make it.
Speaker 1: With a guy from that other movie that was slightly popular, and what's her
Speaker 1: name, from that show you sometimes watch.
Speaker 1: In a movie with two spectacular CGI battle sequences and an advertising campaign that
Speaker 1: will leave you no choice but to see this film.
Speaker 1: See it because it's a movie and all your friends are going.
Speaker 1: In theaters Friday and on DVD in three months